-Welcome to the show.
They love you.
-Hi, guys!
-Yeah!
We love you. It is great
to see you in the flesh.
We've only Zoomed.
-I know.
-Yeah, you're just as gorgeous
and stunning
as you were on Zoom.
-We're not catfishes.
-No, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No, we're not.
We're real people.
-Yeah.
-Thanksgiving is tomorrow.
Happy Thanksgiving early.
-Happy Thanksgiving.
-Jacques Pépin
and I are cooking later.
Do you have a specialty
Thanksgiving dish?
-No. No.
-Oh, okay.
-I don't cook.
-At all?
-No, it's within everybody's
best interest if I don't.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I don't think so.
Have you ever tried?
-I mean, of course I've tried.
But I -- from an early age,
I realized I probably shouldn't.
I nearly burnt down
my mom's oven.
Uh, I tried to make cupcakes.
[ Laughter ]
Some chocolate cupcakes.
But I didn't realize that you
needed, like, I don't know,
baking soda or baking flour.
So, I like -- it just blew up.
[ Laughter ]
And from then on,
she didn't let me --
-You just thought you would
invent a recipe
and see if it worked?
-Correct.
-Wow.
-I know. It's kind of --
it's like this game...
-What did you put in there?
Do you remember?
-Oh, yes.
Um cocoa...
-Uh-huh.
Write this down, everybody.
[ Laughter ]
-Swiss Miss.
-Swiss Miss cocoa?
-Yeah, Swiss Miss.
[ Laughter ]
-You are awesome.
That's so funny.
And it didn't work?
-Delicious.
-No, it's great.
Hot cocoa, yeah.
-Marshmallows, for texture.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
This is a fire hazard.
It really is.
-Some flour...
-Oh, my gosh.
-...and a little bit
of, um, vegetable oil.
-Oh, man, it sounds delicious.
Oh, my gosh.
Next Thanksgiving,
I'm inviting you over.
-You should, you should.
I can make ramen now.
-Oh!
-I will make --
-That's how
we're buddies for life, yeah.
If you can make ramen,
we're buddies for life.
-I can do some late-night ramen.
That's my [bleep] -- sorry.
That's my --
That's my...
[ Laughter ]
...signature dish. Sorry.
-No problem, no problem.
-I told my dad beforehand --
-Maybe we should be back
on Zoom.
[ Laughter ]
We can edit.
-Yeah.
I called my dad beforehand
to tell him it was coming,
and he said,
"Watch your four-letter words."
-[ Gasps ]
[ Laughter ]
And you were thinking
of the other one.
-Sorry, Dad.
-So you slipped with that one.
'Cause it's the worse one.
-It's the worst one.
-
-Yeah, but you started
with the kind of best --
kind of bad one, yeah.
-It's like the PG-13 one.
-Yeah.
And then, yeah.
All right.
So no more of that.
-No, none of that.
[ Laughter ]
-But I want
to know more about you.
You're from South Carolina,
right?
-I am. I'm from a little town
called Goose Creek.
-Goose Creek?
-Goose Creek.
-What a cute name.
-I know.
-I never heard of Goose Creek.
-But there's -- I mean --
I don't know if -- I don't think
there's a lot of geese there.
[ Laughter ]
-Are there creeks there?
-There's a creek, but I've never
seen any geese in it.
-No.
So, whatever.
You know?
Hey.
-Either way, cute name.
I love it.
I'll take it.
It's like a CW town.
-Yeah.
No way.
[ Laughter ]
Did you have that type
of childhood, upbringing?
-Very, very suburbia.
Grew up across the street
from a church.
-Oh, yeah.
-Mom's a real-estate agent.
Dad is a civil engineer.
-Wow.
-And I chose to do everything
they told me not to.
[ Laughter ]
-As a child does.
-As one does.
-But you started acting and you
landed working commercials,
which a lot of child actors
get their start.
In fact, we found one of them.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if you know
that we have this.
Dad, I hope you're watching.
-Which one?
-I want to show --
Here's Madelyn Cline
in a commercial...
for a Chuck E. Cheese
Pizza Maker.
Take a look at this.
-[ Laughs ]
-Today, we're making
Chuck E. Cheese pizza!
-Microwave for just a minute.
Blend the sauce and cheese.
Microwave again.
-Fun food in minutes!
-And you made real
Chuck E. Cheese pizza
with EZ-2 Make!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It looks delicious.
-You know, um...
-It looks really delicious.
-You know, uh...
Have you ever -- you've had
a Lunchable, I'm sure.
-Yes.
-It's like that, the same thing.
-You were ahead of your time.
-There's no baking involved.
-No.
-It's just a turntable.
-The Chuck E. Cheese pizza maker
is a Lunchable.
-It is a Lunchable.
[ Laughter ]
-There's a lawsuit
happening right now.
[ Laughter ]
That's kind of a big deal.
That's great.
Now look at you.
You're in "Glass Onion."
-I know.
-You're in a giant movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The second installment
of the "Knives Out" franchise.
Great cast, by the way.
-Stacked, packed.
-Stacked and packed,
smothered, covered --
and, yeah.
-And smashed.
You got Daniel Craig.
-I know.
-Who I love.
-You have Kate Hudson.
Who I also love.
-The best.
-Yeah. Who did you have
the most scenes with?
Well, I guess all of them.
-Oh, God.
You know, obviously,
I'm on the no-spoiler train.
-So never mind.
-You know, it's an ensemble.
It's very --
It's a heavy ensemble.
-You never need to work
with anyone.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't work with anyone.
-You didn't talk to anyone
on the set.
-I just Zoomed in.
-You didn't see a thing.
[ Laughter ]
"I didn't see anyone at all."
No, that's a great way
to set up the movie.
"I never met anyone
in the cast."
Good.
It keeps everyone guess--
It is a mystery,
so I don't want to ruin it
for anyone else, either, though.
-It is so much fun.
We really leaned into --
I would say we leaned into
the comedy of it all even more
so this time, which was so fun.
It's just -- I mean --
And when you have Kathryn Hahn
on a cast --
-Oh, my gosh
She is funny --
funny and awesome.
She's one of my favorite guests.
I love her.
-Oh, she's the best.
-Also, where did you film this?
It's gorgeous.
-Greece and Serbia.
-Come on.
-Greece and Serbia, yeah.
Can we do "The Tonight Show"
from Greece?
-Can we go?
Can we do it?
-Let's do "The Tonight Show"
from Greece.
If we do it, will you come on?
-Of course I will.
-And we'll just do
a whole "Mamma Mia 3" thing.
-Oh, my --
Are you kidding me?
-Right?
-That's my bread and butter.
-That's my ramen.
Let's do it. Come on!
-Every single weekend
it was "Mamma Mia," orange pie,
gin and tonics, and pools.
-Yeah.
-Oh, I love that.
What is orange pie?
-Oh, it's a Greek thing.
I sound like a foreign --
Not a foreign --a student
who studied abroad.
-Yeah.
-Because I'm like,
"You wouldn't know.
You wouldn't understand.
You had to be there."
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
Exactly, you're just reading
stuff out of a photo or...
"Oh, you haven't tried...
orange pie?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Judging you."
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Madelyn Cline
and Janelle Monae
in "Glass Onion."
Take a look at this.
-This is my second one
of these things.
We did a yacht thing last year.
-Well, that sounds fun.
-[ Chuckles ]
No.
I mean,
when they're all together,
it's kind of the worst.
Duke just treats me
like arm candy,
and they just ignore me.
-Why do you put up with it?
-With Duke?
I'm building my brand.
And he's putting me
on his channel more often.
So he's leaning harder right
into this Mandom stuff.
Like, if I'm going to go
into politics eventually,
I don't think that's a road
I want to go down.
Like, it's expeditious,
but it's kind of a [bleep] show.
Oh.
Here's the pool.
-I'm gonna walk around
a little longer.
I'll catch you over there.
-Okay.
-Hey, it's really great
talking to you, Whiskey.
-You too.
-Mm!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you?
Are you, or are you not?
-Who is she?
What is she all about?
Does she know too much?
-Or too little?
Or is she working on her brand?
Whoo!
I love it.
Madelyn Cline, everybody.
"Glass Onion:
A Knives Out Mystery"
is in theaters now.
You can catch it on Netflix
beginning December 23rd.